okay so when do you play Monopoly I have
not played Monopoly I think since I was
like ten so now I play it when I'm at my
parents house if there's a big family
gathering I don't never play Monopoly
basically played Monopoly before a kid
or when you were stuck inside so I
talked to somebody who played Monopoly
in a Ballroom in the Venetian Hotel in
Macau
I'm Brian Valentine I was the United
States representative to the monopoly
World Championships in 2015 where I
finished third amongst the 28
competitors he taught me all the right
ways to play Monopoly and even make the
game a little shorter all the rules odds
and strategies that can actually help
you win
this is a a Monopoly board from Target
but I took it with me it's in the cow
and asked all the players to sign it for
me just as a keepsake I'm almost getting
in the sports cliches talking about
monopoly but like it was very humbling
to have made it that far against players
who are the best in their country and
work fantastic people and this monopoly
genius he knows heat maps and housing
arbitrage and strategy but he just wants
you to follow the rules okay so what
happens on free parking
do you like collect money from people
there's no money in the free parking I
guess that's the biggest you don't put
money into free parking people see it as
a chance to kind of equalize the game
that's stacked against them if you keep
putting money back in the game
it stops the progress people don't play
the game by their rules
it did it actually wouldn't take quite
so long do you oxygen stuff off no I
remember reading it on the back of the
card but I don't remember I remember
that always feeling a little over my
head in terms of play if you land on it
you don't want it it's got to go up for
oxygen on the spot somebody can buy it
you can start the bidding at $1 I've
seen it happen and I've seen someone
take boardwalk for 20 bucks once you
have the rules in order you've got to go
to the strategy what is the best spot in
monopoly I mean that's the glamour
that's the that's the trademark of
Monopoly like it's boardwalk you got to
get it the object of the game is take
everyone's money and be the only person
left in the game Wow boardwalk certainly
offers the prospect of that you know mm
when you got a hotel on it think about
what it costs to get there
you got to buy each of the two
properties
then it's $200 per house per property
until you get to that level so that's
another thousand dollars on each one to
then get two thousand back and there are
only two of them right most of the other
monopolies have three spaces that you
can hit and then draw rent if you are
building up boardwalk and Park Place
before anybody else is built monopolies
up against you then hell yeah go for it
but if you're in a situation where other
folks have monopolies on that hot side
of the board and you're waiting to throw
the haymaker if you will on boardwalk
and Park Place that's a looser more than
it's a winner
[Music]
you can go on any website and learn the
basic parlor trick that the oranges are
the best monopoly to have are you gonna
now show like like a chart of the
Monopoly board with like a heat map I'm
sad to say that I was I knew that
existed the reason that that is so is
because jail is one of the most often
lando spaces in the game
[Music]
the fact that the comment role is seven
then seven from jail while not an actual
property it's Community Chest six and
eight the next more likely numbers are
st. James and Tennessee Avenue so you
know that the oranges are likely to get
hit on and also by extension the section
between jail and go to jail that that
sides decide you want to be building on
its feast or famine on the other side of
the board so there's a couple more
strategies that are on the practicalness
of massey and if you get to jail early
go ahead and pay up get out of there you
can also use your houses as weapons to
control the game you have thirty-two
houses in the game you've got to build
houses before you can build hotels the
houses have to be physically present and
available to be bought
which is why in a lot of circles you
hear people say about creating a housing
shortage you want to get to the fourth
level so that you can pull the trigger
and go to hotels if you need to or you
could sit on the four houses and keep
other people from having them
okay final question when I ask you what
is the right way to play Monopoly how do
you respond
[Music]
the right way to play Monopoly is just
don't play it don't steal from the bank
and that goes out to my cousin's when we
played when we were 10 I would say is it
just like to win like how to win
[Music]
with honor
it's almost is almost sometimes you feel
like you have this Renaissance era like
sense of honor and dignity not that
we're going around slapping each other
with gloves and having duels or anything
like that but I thought that's the thing
that keeps coming to me is honor of
playing Monopoly allows you to know
people thought you could get to know
people in a way that you know formal
introductions or being co-workers or
whatever doesn't quite show because in a
hour and a half two hour game you're
gonna see how people handle diversity
and see how people handle success you're
gonna see bundled in this this short
format that allows you to kind of to see
who a person is
[Music]
it's monopoly we're talking about
monopoly